Peggy 18
there's a million ways to play the game
in terms of blowing stuff up meaning you
can kind of not be looking to do it but
you see something that you want to blow
up and you're driving along really fast
you aim the car at it and you bail and
there it is so kind of everything's a
weapon and then there's also weapons I
mean it was always about like how
ridiculous can I go so I built something
kind of big and like a little more I'm
like okay so I was like okay I'm gonna
just dial this up to like 30 and see
what happens on a 10 scale and like
perfect I'm like okay well let's see if
we can maintain that for the whole game
and we have so that's awesome you know
we're a part of a section of games that
have been focused on next-gen since the
beginning and this allows us to do
things that maybe the crossover titles
weren't able to do up front
I mean games like Uncharted is obviously
amazing in how they script these
sequences but it's of course entirely
pre-designed and canned we try to avoid
canned experiences as much as possible
so it's all based on cause and effect
the world feels more reactive to what
you do it's not just one explosion you
know you get this shock where you get
two signs fall and get people running
away you get kind of things burning and
it feels more alive we noticed early on
that when things blew up the little
pieces would fly just into the
stratosphere and so we changed to a
pressure based explosion algorithm so
now when things explode it's kind of
more like a real explosion and things
follow a shockwave outwards so you get
more of this kind of debris sort of
spraying and frequently some of the
larger bits you can then interact with
afterwards use those pieces to you know
sort of duel tether them into other
things and you know it's a playground
that seems to be one of the big like
challenges that we face isn't even so
much how do you blow something up it's
easy to blow something up it's
what happens when you blow it up and why
it was open like you know if you have
something that's moving very fast and
colliding with the surface does it blow
up under those circumstances we have to
figure out you know how and when and why
because if you're working on a school
bus and you have to think about like
well what if that school bus was in the
air flying into a mountain because we
have to think about that you know
because it's that kind of game I think
one of the more spectacular things is
newest is the bridge that's fully
indestructible my job is to figure out
sort of what we can do feasibly in most
cases you know depending on where you
sort of place these explosives or how
you explode it different pieces will
sort of activate and come off like if I
decide that I'm gonna blow up the middle
part than the two sides and sometimes
one of them doesn't always fall over
sort of sit there and hanging you know
you see cars kind of like driving off
the edge the vision for it was more and
have taken from movies so we wanted it
to be a bit more spectacular one of the
challenges that we've run into which is
an interesting challenge to have is
making too much stuff too awesome
we have to take some things and be like
alright well so when you kick this can
it's not gonna be in an atom explosion
that's going to you know it's just gonna
maybe a small gas bomb fireball and then
we have done a few things I haven't make
no sense but it's okay because that's
true yeah there is there is some of that
yeah so sure it's not the most realistic
thing in the world but sometimes realism
can be left for a reality and when I'm
playing a game I want to sometimes be
surreal and the game just cause is kind
of about that it's a guy with a grapple
hook on his arm that can do it without
it detaching his arm from his body doing
it too realistically would perhaps
so we tried to amp it up just a bit the
vehicle team really came up with an idea
to change the way destruction work we
spent more time on the fidelity the
vehicle destruction instead of just
doing deformation which is really cool
they actually added things like hinged
parts on it so you actually get the side
view mirror hanging off the side it
seems like a small detail but when
you're driving around and smashing into
a wall you actually get that amazing
return you know it gives life to the
vehicle for the most part our game is
about movement and that traversal space
so the destruction is a joyful response
a reactivity in the world